good morning Hank it's Monday this week
we're going to be learning about the
mating habits of oh come on don't do
that in front of the children
okay so tortoises are majestic reptiles
they can live to be more than 200 years
mmm
is that noise mm-hmm really that's an
actual recording of a tortoise in coitus
mm-hmm
hold on I gotta call Tommy Lee Jones hi
Tommy Lee it's me John Greene I'm gonna
need that magic wand you used in the
film men in black because I need to
unremember something mm-hmm
oh god Tommy we it's happening again so
like I presumed you the majestic Julian
oh come on I think so there are few
things you need to understand about
tortoises in order to understand their
sexuality one tortoises often don't hit
sexual maturity until they're like 20
years old to on average adult male
tortoises weigh 200 pounds more than
females and number three tortoises have
a lot in common with the male characters
on the television phenomenon jersey
shore they don't have jobs they're huge
without being technically overweight and
for both species the primary method of
flirting involves head bobbing okay so
whether a male tortoise is considered
hot is decided mostly by the length of
his neck I mean you know what they say
about tortoises with long necks so the
male tortoises will be hanging out and
be like look my neck is so long and then
the other tortoise would be like my neck
is even longer and whoever has the
longest neck generally gets the most
desirable mating situations okay so
you're a long necked tortoise and you
start to approach your lady friend then
begins the head bobbing the male
tortoise walks up to the female tortoise
and Bob's his head like crazy and an
attempt to I don't know look turtle sexy
at this point one of a few things might
happen it might be that your lady friend
just allows you to mount her now of
course a lot of people wonder about the
actual mechanics of tortoise X this is
pretty straightforward the underside of
the male shell which is called the
plastron is conveniently enough concave
so the shells actually fit surprisingly
well together yeah I don't blame you at
all for walking away from that little
turtle the male tortoise balance is like
a three-legged stool on his hind feet
and his tail and then you know
the noise again thank you wonder the
worst thing about the noise this noise
mm-hmm is the only noise tortoises ever
make like occasionally they like make
hissing sounds but in terms of really
utilizing their vocal chords just this
so like that's how it goes when
everyone's enthusiastic about mating but
sometimes the lady tortoises say you
know I don't really want to have someone
who weighs 200 pounds more than me hump
me in that situation the male tortoise
will walk around to the front of the
female and start biting her feet he does
this because eventually she will retract
her feet into her shell thereby
rendering her immobile so he can run
around and you know you stay classy
giant tortoise once insemination occurs
the female tortoises lay their eggs in a
shallow nest and eight months later baby
tortoises who will grow up alone in a
terrifying world where this passes for
love hey guy can't wait for your song on
Wednesday on Friday we'll be learning
about giant squids not a van gir but of
love by the way nerdfighters both this
giant squid of anger shirt designed by
nerdfighter von del Swain and this dftba
shirt which reminds everyone who looks
at your chest not to forget to be
awesome are available now at dftba.com
link in the doobly-doo they're in stock
and ship immediately at least until we
run out of them also please go to
project for awesome comm and sign up for
the project for awesome mailing list the
mailing list is one of the main ways we
have of organizing so we can descend
upon videos about nonprofits and bring
them to the world and yes I know that my
glasses are crooked my son is 10 months
old he is a glasses monster please
forgive me Hank I'll see you on
Wednesday by the way I'm not going to
lie learning all of this has
dramatically affected my relationship
with the Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
I mean seriously Donatello I did not
expect you to be a biter of lady feet